[Music]
just how permanent are some of the most
shocking character deaths that take
place in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness pretty permanent
it seems but like all superhero stories
there's always an out keep watching for
what we mean
warning just in case the title didn't
give it away spoilers ahead from the
death of he who remains in loki to
spider-man tambourine with doctor
strange's spell and spider-man no way
home a lot has transpired over the last
couple of years in the mcu that has
nothing to do with thanos all of those
actions have seemingly created a ripple
effect causing the multiverse itself to
splinter and crack that leads us to
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness where the titular sorcerer meets
a teenager by the name of america chavez
she has the ability to travel across the
multiverse usually accidentally this has
attracted the attention of a demon who
wants that ability for itself naturally
it falls on strange and wong's shoulders
to protect the girl and the very fabric
of the multiverse it's not just our
strangest reality he has to protect but
the fate of every reality as such it
should come as no surprise that a lot
hangs in the balance including the lives
of our heroes and sadly a view of
earth's mightiest do indeed bite the
dust while death is rarely permanent in
the comics there's a good chance these
deaths are going to stick when doctor
strange and america chavez travel across
the multiverse they land in a reality
where their version of doctor strange
died fortunately he helped establish a
coalition of heroes known as the
illuminati to protect this universe from
all kinds of threats including their
version of thanos the illuminati will
see you stephen this iteration of the
illuminati consists of mordo professor x
captain carter captain marvel black bolt
and reed richards richards is played by
a debuting john krasinski while mordo
captain carter and black bolt are all
played by returning actors to tell edgy
04 haley atwell and anson mount
respectively professor x is the patrick
stewart one reprising his role from the
fox x-men movie series though there are
indications he's playing a professor x
from a different universe and the
captain marvel here is not the one you
might expect it's lashanna lynch who
played maria rambo in the captain marvel
movie it's a ton of fun to see all these
different characters occupy the same
space together but viewers don't get a
lot of time with them nearly as quickly
as they're introduced they're dispatched
courtesy of scarlet witch one by one she
kills each member of the illuminati
except mordo making black bolts voice
implode in on himself while reed
richards turns into spaghetti it's one
of the most brutal sequences ever
depicted in the mcu and fans shouldn't
expect these heroes to return at least
in any way we know them all of these
heroes exist in an alternate universe
they're not part of the proper mcu
continuity which is said to take place
in the universe 616 curiously also the
same designation for the comics marvel
universe there's a good chance we'll
never go to this illuminati universe
again so it really wouldn't make much
sense to bring the heroes back and even
if these specific heroes remain dead
that doesn't mean there aren't other
versions of them across the multiverse
the loki series of disney plus
introduced the idea of variants there
are an infinite number of possibilities
out there in the multiverse there's an
endless number of different versions of
characters for fans to meet we have the
chance to see a few of these variants in
action in what if one of the most
intriguing characters to come out of
that series was captain carter not only
is she a hero in her own right but she
goes on to join the multiversal avengers
while there isn't confirmation yet it's
safe to surmise that the captain carter
we see in what if is different from the
live-action one we see in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness after all
one of the universes doctor strange and
america chavez traveled through is
animated so who's to say that captain
carter from what if isn't from one of
these so even though versions of these
characters are killed in multiverse of
madness this may not be the last time we
see some version of captain carter and
the other members of the illuminati in
the mcu especially intriguing as john
krasinski's role as reed richards does
this mean mr fantastic exists in earth
616 would this version of reed look like
krazynski or could he be completely
different much like the various
spider-men who populated no way home
seemingly krasinski's appearance here is
a tease for a future fantastic four role
but anything is possible fans will just
have to wait and see what the future of
the mcu holds
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]